welcome to Conor O'Brien needs a friend
wonderful show
today for you I do I thought you meant
just in general this is a wonderful show
I thought you meant that you know I
should just say that yeah wow what a
wonderful show not today's but just in
general and I gotta say I'm gonna
include everything I've ever been in
fall but
hey welcome to Conor Brian needs a
friend and what an incredible body of
work hi
and what an incredible body
well there's some problems there I'm
working on it I'm working on my body I
am working on chiseling my way out of my
covid slump okay that's good how about a
little
something like yeah and you're doing a
really good job you look good yeah
you're doing okay so hot Jesus man
you're such a you're so jacked uh your
joint is always by Sonam Obsession wise
ass
to my right and Matt Gourley who I know
has kind things to say about my efforts
to lose the Old Coach wow
can you do that no but seriously I don't
know about you guys did you guys I did
during uh choking someone else's scrotum
come on let's go wow this is all gonna
come out fine but there's nothing wrong
with token on scrotums he doesn't have
to get out let's try and reel this in
and yes there is because if you're
choking and your windpipe is impaired
that's terrible yeah it's true
regardless of what it is so just choking
in general is bad it doesn't be a
scrotum it's called stroking
incredible
all the time now and just shakes his
head like this was a fine podcast you're
raining on the parade Adam we're having
a great scrotum time yeah you brought me
into this Adam it's your fault I know I
don't know about anybody else but uh I
let things go a little bit over covid I
think about a lot of us did I don't
think you did Gorly you seem to be a
trim fellow oh at first I really worked
hard to stay in shape and then I really
let it go when the baby was born and put
on more weight than I ever have are you
doing
the thing that I used to do with my
brother Neil we used to we realized that
we loved Gerber's baby food oh so when
my brother Justin was born my mom got
this Gerber's food and we were always
famished and there was a lot of us in
the house and we never thought there was
enough food the Gerber's banana is
absolutely delicious do you not remember
we did a whole segment about this and I
bro we did I brought in okay
flavor of of choice was the vanilla
custard pudding and that was delicious
that is amazing so I remember okay now I
remember we did talk about this when I
was an adult but my thing is that that
baby food is so good yeah but in general
when little kids are around I don't know
if you're doing this sauna but when
little kids are around their food is so
much better than adults you should try
it now what is it like oh it's these
like pouches made by Jennifer Garner and
these little creamy uh like wafer
biscuits Jennifer Garner have to do with
anything she just knows what babies like
that's true I just love when you said oh
this incredible pouch made by Jennifer
Garner you know what what are you
getting paid on the side because that's
all I know I have no idea what the story
is you don't even care
because my kids eat that too the what
it's Once Upon A Farm it's a delicious
yeah pouch organic it's delicious let's
make it send a shipment to us let's make
it clear right now this is not a paid
promotion or anything but it could be I
could laugh it could be I laughed
because as clearly you're just Star
Struck you're feeding your child you
don't even know what's in the food so
what did you give your kid today you
know I gave her a cracker made by the
situation from Jersey Shore yeah exactly
what's in the cracker just oil I don't
know yeah tanning oil uh yeah I don't
know anything about it Amanda just told
me that like wow this Jennifer Garner's
company makes this and I tasted it it's
delicious it is really good yeah it's
good it's all about that pouch life now
yeah yeah you can even get empty pouches
and fill it in with food you make right
what do you mean an empty pouch why
would you get an empty because the kids
know to like grab it and and suck the
food out do you realize we're raising a
whole generation of kids that think that
all meals should be eaten out of a pouch
yeah they're going to be gathering as
old people around Thanksgiving tables
sucking mashed turkey out of a pouch
and that's what everyone's going to be
doing if we don't stop it now Soylent
Green it is bad that's all right yeah
and you're getting the nutrients it's
like huffing I don't want this if I saw
babies just holding bags up to their
faces and inhaling it they look like
addicts at a gas station at four in the
morning yeah my babies need it every day
if they don't get it they start typing
their pouches oh yeah I watched their
pouch life I watched your boys attack a
bag of little look like little cheese
balls yeah little Puffs yeah they'd love
them Puffs and you open the bag ripped
open the bag and just poured a bunch on
the table yeah and it was like pouring
Chum in the water in a shark infested
tank just your two kids Mikey and Trump
and then they're like a piece of the
table was gone was it like Hungry Hungry
Hippos it really is yeah
and I didn't realize her babies their
jaws detached and they go out like the
hippo and Slide the pellet back in
it also helps that one of your kid is
bright red and the other is bright blue
and a for Garner send some food yeah